this circle represents one whole the
circle right here represents one whole
if we know that we can answer
what fraction of the circle is shaded in
blue below so down here what fraction is
in blue
let's start back up here with the hole
this hole is divided into one
two
three equal sized pieces so it's divided
into
thirds three equal sized pieces
and each of those pieces each of those
pie pieces is one third is one of the
thirds
so knowing that let's go down here to
these ones
and let's see how many of these
one-third pieces here's one-third
another one-third
another one-third shaded in blue another
one and another one so we have one two
three four five
thirds
we have five
thirds shaded in blue below